what is the likelihood of China joining
TPP well I mean it's true that China has
spoken about it the vice finance
minister I was talking to the Peterson
Institute in Washington just last year
and he said you know there's been an
internal debate in China about about
joining it and there's also debate
within the United States there's a sense
in China actually that the US wants to
go ahead with this deal without China's
participation but the thing is that
China's just not ready to join you know
Obama we just heard him going through
that litany of various benchmarks that
need to be reached in order for a
country to join and certainly China is
not able to actually join or meet those
benchmarks for many years so it would be
years although it's not out of the
question that sometime China would
become integrated into it the other
important thing is to remember who
Obama's speaking to when he says that
because he's still trying to get
fast-track authority from Congress in
order to put this deal through if they
can actually get the agreements among
the other emember 11 members now if they
get that fast track Authority what that
would mean is that there would be a
straight up and down vote in Congress
and that Congress wouldn't be able to
actually say no we want to have
amendments here in amendments there
because that would just slow down the
process incredibly and so Obama's really
trying to reassure Democrats because
it's the Democrats some Democrats who
are worried that they would be losing
jobs are if the deal is signed and goes
ahead he's trying to assure them that
maybe China will come in and if China
does come in it will have to have the
same standards that are now you know
prevalent in the United States yeah and
that that would mean that there wouldn't
be jobs going overseas well you know
some would say globally that this is
more than just a trade pact that this
really takes on geo political
connotations yeah I mean I think you're
referring to ash Carter the balance
secretary last month was saying that for
him the TPP is as important as another
aircraft carrier and what he's talking
about is the whole Bri balance toward
Asia and this is an economic and
military rebalance but his point is that
you can only have
military strength me military
superiority if you've got a very strong
economy and he also pointed out that the
TPP and the number is you could could
actually boost our US exports by about a
hundred and twenty three billion dollars
over the next decade so you can see it's
actually pretty important for the United
States that would contributed a nice
amount to the Pentagon it'd be helpful
yeah